[Musique]
bien que la parole comme si ces
miliciens depuis cette semaine peut
imaginer que je peux pas passer à côté
sujet doit de l'enquète qu'on est en
train de voir sur le décès de gc chaiwan
en septembre 2020 les témoignages qui
sortent des infirmiers du personnel
médical des familles aussi des personnes
qui sont victimes de discrimination en
milieu hospitalier et le tout d'émotion
qui est vécu au temps des deux côtés
d'un côté on parle d'une chasse aux
sorcières on parle d'un système qui les
supportent pas de conditions de travail
qui sont vraiment inhumaines et de
l'autre côté on parle quand même d'un
système qui par le passé et encore
aujourd'hui fait la discrimination
envers certaines populations qui vont
chercher des soins de santé
je dirais pas que c'est pas pour moi une
réalité qui est vécue depuis mon enfance
que je vois que j'ai vu les interactions
entre des patients autochtone des
patients allochtone et certains médecins
ou certaines des infirmières et
infirmiers est très patient avec les
patientes allochtone et tout d'un coup
changer totalement d'attitude quand
c'était des patients autochtone soit la
différence entre quand est ce que je
vends le médecin j'ai mal
qu'est ce qui va se passer et on
attendait madame l'accord est venu vous
voir ce sera pas long notre nourriture
sans ordinateur et je sais pas là aux
acteurs et de voir vraiment une
interaction totalement différent en tant
qu'observateur pas que cette matrice
siers je peux pas à semblant que ça
n'existait pas je pouvais faire semblant
que le traitement change pas d'un
patient à l'autre
et quand on écoute certains témoignages
certains internautes pour par rapport à
l'infirmière de dire qu elle a été très
méchante temps qu'elle a parlé
joyce très méchante ccc c'est quelque
chose d'autre que de dire mon
comportement nos fermes et par rapport à
voir un regard juste et neutre par
rapport à ma passion et ma patiente
aujourd'hui est mort dont elle n'a pas
été uniquement très méchant elle s'est
fermé et on a vu comment dans tout le
processus médical de joyce et chaque one
les gens se sont fermées à 1 donc le
système s'est fermé à joyce et n'a pas
permis que on interprète sa douleur sa
maladie ces conditions avec le même
regard que c'était un patient allochtone
par exemple elle avait mal donc je
n'interpréterais que c'était du sevrage
est pas c'était de la douleur comme un
portrait qui pourrait vivre la douleur
si c'était un homme blanc aisés qui
avait ça s qui seraient ensevelies dans
la tête des docteurs des infirmiers ou
est-ce qu'ils seraient en douleur parce
que les opioïdes
c'est quand même un soin de santé d
appuyer de prescription un homme blanc
riche en recevoir pour les mêmes
douleurs qu'une femme autochtone mais
par exemple la réaction qu'on va avoir
des ciseaux pull sera pas être traités
de la même manière
c'est une autochtone qui se drogue c'est
un homme blanc qui souffrent vous pouvez
comprendre que c'est pas uniquement les
seuls enjeux que j'ai entendu dans les
témoignages du fait qu'un docteur peut
refuser de donner des soins parce qu'ils
interprètent la patiente est un sevrage
donc c'est comme dire ont retraité sa
problématique de d'extrêmement mais on
n'écoute même plus sa douleur grave nef
quand même se faire faire une
colonoscopie ce sont des procédures
douloureuse et c'est très difficile
d'entendre ces témoignages de deux êtres
autochtones passe en premier c'est
d'ailleurs la frmr a témoigné en disant
je leur ai traités pareil si ça avait
été une femme blanche chez ubs avec cet
enfant
il s'y met tous deux rendu compte que tu
quand même la discrimination envers les
conditions de vie
quelqu'un parce que sur le bs alors que
robin ça rajoute une couche pas non plus
parce que peut-être tonnes donc il ya
une problématique des discriminations il
ya une problématique de voir les
patients de différents niveaux et le
traitement quotidienne à ces patients là
vont être interprétés par des à priori
par les discrets les ti situation que tu
entretiens de taper donc c'est
extrêmement rageant parce que c'est la
vie de quelqu'un qui a dépendu de ses a
priori là et que le système en écrit
breake les personnes sont remplies
préjugés mais que ces préjugés là que tu
les as you pas ça veut pas dire que ça
doit transformer le système de santé
nous les laissons et tu vas recevoir
donc beaucoup de colère il ya beaucoup
de virages aussi parce que quand on voit
dans les commentaires des médias des
publications comme l'ont dit certains
articles certains articles sont écrits
d'une façon très neuf et donc utilisent
encore aujourd'hui l'interprétation ou
limo qui servait à nous décrire avant
qu'on essaie d'avoir moins de
discrimination dans les langages donc
vous savez comment on parle des
autochtones dans les journaux en 1990
mesalles a des relents de trouver des
traces et une patiente mais le côté la
discrimination existe encore parce que
la réaction du public québécois est pas
autour de la justice pour joyce et
chaque one
je vois que présentement c'est
interprété comme un procès sur est ce
que le québec est raciste ou non que le
québec soit raciste ou non c'est pas un
enjeu d'une seule cause
c'est un système dont on doit enlever
les interactions de discrimination et le
québec sera pas raciste mais comment
c'est interprété ses poèmes justice pour
un individu c'est vraiment un procès
d'intention du peuple québécois
et là ça fait toute la différence
comment les gens interagissent comment
les gens écoutent les témoignages comme
ils font des procès d'intention à joyce
et chaque fois j'ai eu des commentaires
comme je savais qu'il y avait anguille
sous roche
s'attendent à ce que joy soit la
parfaite victime est présentement on
essaie de décortiquer le kono joyce et
chacun pour montrer qu'elle n'est pas si
parfaite comme victime mais est ce qu
est une parfaite victime
ça existe ou est ce que ces demandes et
pour un coût qui conquit qui parle des
enjeux autochtones
donc vous comprenez c'est extrêmement
émotif c'est extrêmement difficile et
c'est bourré aussi de petites bombes qui
explosent un peu partout dans les
commentaires dans les médias sociaux
puisque c'est là que ça se passe
à cause des restrictions et qui font
revivre les remettre en place justement
tout ans et ses réactions qu'on a par
rapport à la discrimination par rapport
au racisme ordinaire qu'on a avec des
citoyens et par rapport au racisme
systémique qu'ils disent dans les
institutions énormément de choses à
décortiquer un sujet très chaud très
difficile à avoir une conversation qui
vient chercher des expériences de vie
extrêmement désagréable j'ai tout allez
les
les membres des communautés autochtones
et qui vient toucher aussi à quelque
chose à un sujet qui n'a pas été discuté
dans la société québécoise
alors je vous souhaite une belle semaine
je vous souhaite de de vous garder le
moral haut d'avoir le coeur léger parce
que ce sera pas un hors jeu que va être
facile à discuter et les résultats
peuvent être très indicateur du futur de
la réconciliation au québec
le swing des années